every time he takes center stage her
goes crazy president Hassan rouhani
symbolizes everything these young
Iranians wish for in a president the
Hazara me
he brought us more security more
economic stability and more personal
freedom I've been able to walk the
streets more easily in the past few
years
can't a man fare for me the most
important thing during his presidency
has been the stability of prices and the
exchange rate to the dollar not
something but to do a lot barge on the
nuclear deal was a great success and a
turning point in his presidency and I
think for that alone he deserves for
extra years if he beats the principal
astiz rival party they're confident he
will fulfill the promises he has not
kept so far among the young educated
Iranians here in northern Iran president
rouhani and Jose great support his
principles however have put their focus
on Iran's lower classes which they tried
to win over with monetary promises
Terrence McCauley before examples as he
will create millions of jobs and Abraham
RACI a powerful cleric close to Iran's
supreme leader says he will dribble the
cash handouts to the poor critics
accused both of them of making promises
they won't be able to keep the big
question is the voters believe them we
leave the event for a while to meet
someone who might know Hossein cannon
Amogh Adam once ran for president
himself and says right now rouhani is
leading in the polls but he's far from
the 50% he needs so in the coming days
it's all about convincing the third of
Iranians who are still undecided in C
that said the Sheva Hampton
we call them gray voters they usually
decide on Election Day I get on the test
if they vote for rouhani he will make it
in the first round
cuz I gonna Testament biggie thank you
that I know if they don't cast their
votes at all there's going to be a
second round and tell what the go to the
rochesters back at the campaign rally
people know what that means in a runoff
with only one principal astray Ville
rouhani's chances of winning are slim
so they will be sure to intensify their
efforts in the coming days to keep their
favorite in office
[Music]